- We added almost a half,
almost 500,000 new jobs,
net new jobs, total new jobs
in the state, which is a lot.
We cut more taxes
than ever been cut,
but we also raised the
average income level
the fastest rate in the country.
We were the fastest
improving state
in the country in
education results, K, 12.
We did it in our way,
not the way that is current,
being proposed by the
current administration.
We actually made a program
where community colleges
and our technical schools
could be open to everyone.
We actually had a
free technical school
and community college
program for folks.
So, the idea being, let's
level the playing field
on the front
so we don't have to do so much
to help folks on the backend.
And I think we finally just
made this a type of place
that people want to live.
(funky music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is a visiting professor
of political science
at Vanderbilt University,
the former two term
governor of Tennessee
and author of the new book,
"Faithful Presence: The
Promise and Peril of Faith
in the Public Square,"
Governor Bill Haslam.
Welcome to "The Rubin Report."
- Well, thanks for having me.
It's good to be with
you and your viewers.
- Well, I'm glad to have
you on because, you know,
we get sent an
awful lot of books.
We get sent an awful
lot of pitches,
and I can't have everybody
on, but I wanted to do this
because I thought what you're
talking about in this book,
the blend of politics and faith
is particularly interesting.
I found it interesting
at a personal level,
just because of my own sort of
political and
spiritual evolution.
And that sort of
will be the framework
of where we start here.
But first, you're
in Tennessee now.
I was there a few weeks ago.
They're doing something
right in Tennessee.
I know you're not
the governor anymore,
but you must be happy with
the state of the state, right?
- You know, our founders
kind of had this great idea,
like, let the states be
laboratories of democracy.
Let them all do
it their own way.
And I think states like
Tennessee have chosen to be
lower tax, encouraging
business growth.
And I think you're seeing
the result of that.
People get to choose
where they live,
and we have a lot more inflow
than we do outgo these days.
I'll put it that way.
- Yeah, before we get into
the specifics of the book,
do you miss being in
government right now?
- You know, listen,
being in government,
it's such a great chance
to make a difference.
I don't want to sound
corny, but it, you know,
it's a great way to help change
the trajectory of
people's lives.
And so, I do miss that,
but I'm also somebody
that I kind of believe in
the whole term limit idea.
Eight years of governor
is the right amount.
And if you can get
something done,
you should be able to
get it done in that time,
and then hand the baton to the
next person to let them run.
- So what were
some of the things,
I have a whole
list of them here,
some of the things
that you would say were
your big successes
when you were governor?
- You know, I, well, I
mean, several things.
I mean, I think we
added almost a half,
almost 500,000 new jobs,
net new jobs, total new jobs
in the state, which is a lot.
We cut more taxes
than ever been cut,
but we also raised the
average income level,
the fastest rate in the country.
We were the fastest improving
state in the country
in education results, K, 12.
We did it in our
way, not the way
that is current, being proposed
by the current administration.
We actually made a program
where community colleges
and our technical schools
could be open to everyone.
We actually had a
free technical school
and community college
program for folks.
So the idea being, let's
level the playing field
on the front
so we don't have to do so much
to help folks on the backend.
And I think we finally just
made this a type of place
that people want to live.
And, we said to
businesses, we get it.
Jobs get created when
people put capital at risk.
And I think business
owners appreciated that.
- You said to me right
before we started recording,
"Boy, you'd save a lot of money
if you move from
Cali to Tennessee."
What do you think it is
about blue state governors
that they can't understand
that lowering taxes
actually incentivizes
business and commerce
and people to make decisions
for themselves, et cetera?
- Well, part of the
problem is they're stuck
with some legacy
costs that it's,
it takes, it's going to
take a while to work out of.
So you have these
pension obligations
that a lot of states have
that you can't just snap your
fingers and make them go away.
They have to be addressed.
And I feel sorry for some
of the current governors
because it was people in
the past who promised things
that couldn't be delivered.
But I honestly think a lot
of it's just not appreciation
for, again, for how
jobs get created.
And folks think, well, jobs
get created by the government,
and we know that's not
true, but you know, that's,
at the end of the, for the
government to create a job,
they have to take tax money
away from folks to do that.
We know jobs get
created, like I said,
when people invest capital,
and they invest capital where
there's a more sure, you know,
predictor of return,
and keeping taxes low
is one way to do that.
- So you were a businessman
before you were in government.
So you know a little
something about this.
- I hope so.
I mean, again, you
know, I, being in,
people say, well, we gonna
put a business person
in the mayor, governor,
president's seat,
and, well, it's a
different world, okay?
But there's some things
you learn in business
that do adapt to
be in government.
One of those is you've got
to make the budget work
and you've got to have
a product, your state,
you know, people get to
choose where they live,
that makes it worth it for
people to choose your state.
- Okay, so I want to
talk about the book.
The title is "Faithful
Presence: The Promise and Peril
of Faith in the Public Square."
So first off, just
on a personal side,
can you tell me a little
bit about your faith?
- Yeah, you know, back
when I was in high school,
decided that the best I could,
I would try to follow
Jesus with my life.
And it's really what
led me into politics.
I kind of, like a lot of folks,
spent some time in business,
thought about doing a
couple of other things,
ended up being talked
into running for mayor,
and being mayor and
governor both, to me,
felt like the very
best place to serve.
And because of that,
you know, they,
you talk about job as
being a calling it,
this, both jobs being
mayor and governor
felt more like home than
anything I'd ever done.
- So I think a lot of
people think, well,
how can you be a person of
faith and be in politics,
meaning politics is dirty.
It's messy.
You gotta do unethical things.
You gotta lie, you gotta cheat.
You gotta, all the stuff.
How did you mitigate
all of those things?
And maybe the temperature
was a little bit different
years ago when you were
doing this, than right now.
- Yeah, well, it
hasn't been that long.
Just been out of
office for two years,
so temperature wise, but the
temperature is definitely,
the temperature
continues to rise.
You're right.
So, I think, people say,
gosh, well is it hard
to be a Christian in politics?
I'd say, is it a hard to
be a Christian in business,
or in media or anything else?
Is it hard to not be
anxious about things?
Is it hard to not have pride in,
or to have the wrong kind
of pride, to be arrogant?
I think that the
thing about business,
or, thing about being in
government, I tell folks is,
there's a quote from Martin
Luther, the theologian,
where he said, hey, send
your very best into politics
because dealing with the
ambiguities of life there
take real insight.
You know, in preaching, the
Holy Spirit does all the work.
You have to figure
out how to live
in this gray world of politics.
And I think you can do that.
And one of the things I'm
trying to encourage folks is,
don't be scared off from
being involved in politics,
from being in the public square,
because it is such a great
place to change lives
and to make a difference.
- So how would you
describe the promise
of faith in the public square?
Obviously, we have a
separation of church and state,
but you also have
the right to believe
whatever you want to believe.
How would you
describe that promise?
- Yeah, I mean, so one of
the clear things, one of the,
again, the bright, the
incredibly smart things
our founders did was say
that religion is so important,
we're not going to let the
government play a role in it.
So you can't, we're
not going to have
a government
established religion.
But the second part of that,
when people talk about
separation of church and state,
it also says we're not
going to do anything
to prohibit the
free exercise of it.
So again, that's the
brilliance of the founders.
Like, faith is too,
religion is too important
for the government
to be in charge of.
And that's what I think
is really important.
So, I like that.
I don't want us to have a
government established religion.
You know, that's,
whenever you have that,
the church doesn't thrive
well in that environment.
Look at Europe in that, where
the church is fairly dead,
where historically you had a
government established church.
I think we do better if the
government stay out of it.
But again, not to stop people
from practicing their faith
in the way that they
think they should.
- Yeah, are you worried
that the church in America,
I would say the church,
but also temples,
from a Jewish perspective.
- Sure.
- Probably almost
every religion,
that they are
becoming incredibly
politicized right now?
- Well, I am.
I think there's two big things.
First of all, there's,
I mean, you know,
if you look at the
Gallup surveys,
the number of people who say
I'm a member of a temple or
a church or place of worship
has decreased dramatically.
And some of that is just
cultural changes in our country.
So people don't feel like, well,
I have to go to temple
or I have to go to church
to be a respectable
member of society.
And some of that's okay.
It's something we're
actually kind of, you know,
sifting through
what's true faith
and what is that that
I'm just doing because,
for appearance's sake.
So I think some of
that change is good.
I do worry about
what you said that
we can politicize our faith.
That's one of the reasons
I wrote this book.
The object is to be used
by God, not to use God.
And if you look at
scripture, it does,
God doesn't treat
lightly those people
who are using Him
for other purposes.
- So, as these things
get more politicized,
do you sense that sort
of what has happened
on the other side of the aisle,
on the democratic
side of the aisle,
is that there just is
no attachment to faith?
I mean, they, the Democrats
used to talk about faith
a little bit more.
Biden sort of does,
but then, seemingly,
his policies are in conflict
with the ideals of his faith.
At least that's what a
lot of people would say.
- Yeah, I think some of that
depends on what, you know,
where you are in the
Democratic Party.
You think about the
African-American part
of the Democratic Party, that,
the faith is still a
strong part of who they are
and strong part of
how they identify.
And I, sometimes I wonder
if the Democrat Party
is leaving a lot of
people of faith behind
in the way they address issues.
I think that that would be
the fear on the Democrat side.
On the Republican side, like
I said, is that this idea
that some folks think, well,
I'm gonna use my politics
to direct my faith instead
of the other way around.
- Right, so, let's talk
about that peril part,
because you're talking about
the promise and the peril.
So what was the peril for you
as you were trying to
incorporate your spiritual side
to a public life?
- Well, I think this,
one of the things
that I noticed from
being in office
was that people of faith
didn't act any different
than nonbelievers in
the public square.
They were just as likely to
be hateful on the internet.
You talked about the
temperature rising.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- They were just as likely
to hide behind the anonymity
to send a message that you
would never say face to face.
And were just as likely
to be people, you know,
it says, you know,
God is opposed to the proud
but gives grace to the humble.
We're just as likely to be proud
and think we have the
right answer on this issue
as folks who were saying, we
want to get to the best answer.
And I think when
politics works best,
it's about folks saying,
it's not me arguing with you
about which one of us is right.
It's talking with you, and
then let's figure out together
if we can solve this problem.
- Yeah, were you
worried at times,
if you were to talk about
your faith, not even publicly,
but if you were
privately in a meeting,
you've got your crew around you,
not even your
political opponents,
but just your own
people around you,
that if you were to bring
faith too much into it,
that that was going
to cause a problem?
- You know, I, some of that,
just to be blunt with you,
it's a question of where you
are in the country, right?
There's certain
places in Tennessee
that's probably a little easier
to have that conversation
than it might be in
California, right?
- [Dave] Sure.
- But I think that the
reality is regardless
of where you live is to be
true to what you believe
and not to be letting
your politics change that
or affect those things that you,
your most deeply held beliefs.
- Yeah, are you sensing
any sort of a spiritual
renewal right now?
I mean, I know you mentioned
that there's a certain amount
of people leaving the
church, leaving the temples,
that sort of thing.
But I sense a new, something
on the horizon here
as we're watching the secular
world just go bananas.
- I actually do.
I think folks look around and,
you know, it's interesting.
If you think about the
secular world is the one
that always in the
past would say, well,
there is no such
thing as truth, right?
That you, that truth
is all relative,
that well, you think
this, I think that,
We both, I mean,
actually in California,
there's a proposal
right now to say
that math is not objective.
- Right, two plus two
doesn't equal four anymore
over here in crazy Cali.
- Right, part of that is
this whole idea of, like,
nobody can define
truth for someone else.
But I think we've seen in a
lot of the marches for justice,
you know, if you're
asking for justice,
you're saying there is such
a thing as truth, right?
And I think what you're
seeing is a world that says,
if we don't have any truth,
we have some problem.
And ultimately to
say there's truth
means there has to be
some transcendent being
who's determining,
you know, truth beyond
what's just the truth of this
age, if that makes sense.
- No, well, it does make sense.
What about the people,
where do you think the people
that are the non-believers
fit into this?
I, one of the things that
I've been most interested by
lately is that there is a
group, Atheists for Liberty,
that I've now seen at
some conservative events.
It's, doesn't seem like
it traditionally fits
within the conservative tent,
but the ideals
they're espousing,
minus the faith part,
are those same ideals
of freedom and liberty
and things of that nature.
- Right, well, one of
the first things I'd say
to people of faith is
that people who say
that I'm really not a believer,
that they're not
the enemy, okay?
That's, and, too
much, it's become,
it's a good guy versus bad guys.
You know, that the enemy
is all of the real issues
that we're dealing with in life.
And so, I think, to
me, that's interesting.
Like you said, I,
then, I can't remember
the name of the group,
but that's a good, so -
- Atheists for Liberty.
- You said non, right, okay.
So, to me, that's
interesting, like, that
they're saying there is such
a thing as liberty, okay?
There is such a thing that
matters in terms of freedom,
which, because there
is such a thing, again,
that matters in
terms of justice.
And I think building on
all that is something
that we would want to encourage.
- Are you, I ask a
lot of my guests this,
but are you hopeful
for America right now?
I think related to
the faith piece,
a lot of people are really,
really worried about the future.
A lot of young people
just can't see a path
that kind of makes
sense going forward.
- So, I love your question
and that's why I
wrote this book.
You know, you write,
I wrote this book
really to people
of faith saying,
the country's really
discouraged, right?
Because we're divided.
We're pretty equally
divided, you know.
The last eight presidential
races have been close.
Senate's 50, 50.
The house has six
votes separating it
and probably will flip
the next election.
We're divided and
we're mad about it.
And then, we're not even mad.
We think the other
side is, you know,
coming at it from bad motives,
and a lot of people are
going around saying,
what's going to
get us out of this?
And I, my point would be,
maybe here's where people
of faith, you know,
scripture talks about, you know,
there's salt that keeps
the meat from going bad.
And if the meat goes bad,
it's not the meat's fault.
It's the salt's fault.
And so, I'm saying
to people of faith,
we should start with ourselves.
And if we're supposed
to be the salt,
if the meat's going bad,
if the culture seems to be
going the wrong direction,
maybe it's our fault.
And how can we change
that conversation?
- So, in essence, you would say
we need to sort of spiritual
revival in some way,
that the answers are not coming
from getting the
right governors in
with the right
marginal tax rates?
- Well, listen, I think having
good government matters.
So it's not one
versus the other.
I'm just saying
that people of faith
can be part of who
changes the conversation.
Then back to what you said is,
the temperature
continues to go up.
Maybe we could be people
who change the way
that conversation
happens in the sense of
when I'm having a
discussion with somebody,
my job is not to put them down
or to come up with a really
clever retort to them.
But my job is to
listen and understand
and say, what's the really the
best answer we can come here?
Because if I really
am a person of faith,
my issue here is not
to be proven right.
- That's tough in an age
of social media, huh?
- Yeah, no question.
So it's, that's
what's made it really,
people say what's different
today from 30 years ago?
I'd say 30 years ago, we
didn't have this environment
that rewards people for
being social media stars
instead of actually
getting things done.
It's like, till we have a
lot of people in Washington
who are like, I'm
not really a senator.
I just play one on TV
or on social media.
And, as you know, it's real
easy to be a social media star.
So, the hopeful thing is
maybe we can encourage people
who want to say, I'm
here not to make a point,
but to make a difference
in a world that gives you
a lot of applause
for making a point.
- Yeah, do you think some
of this is just the fact
that so many people
have a voice now,
that part of the chaos is
just that we're
getting more voices,
where in the old days we just
didn't have all the voices,
and so we sort of thought
we were more unified,
but maybe we weren't?
- I think that's fair.
And people always say, you know,
what are the party
fathers and mothers
of the Republican Party?
What are they doing about this?
Which, I said, you
know, there are,
there is no such thing anymore.
I mean, you know, the, there
is no backroom group of folks
who are deciding,
making these decisions.
It's become a very flat world,
and everybody is
getting their voice.
So I do think there is, some
of that is this is just,
everybody has their own
microphone and megaphone now.
But I think that that
cacophony of noise
has led folks to saying, well,
how do we ever get direction
and vision out of this?
- Yeah, well, I want to
give you the last word.
You've been hopeful throughout.
One of the things I've
try to do on my show,
on my daily show and
in my interviews,
I want people to feel hope,
because this is so
screwy right now,
and a lot of people are
feeling kinda depressed.
Give me one more
pitch for for hope
and how people that want
to be involved politically,
how, in your view, their faith
can help them in that regard.
- Well, I would say this.
Don't give up on the
public square, okay?
As messy as it is, as
frustrating as it is,
because the public square
is still that place
where you can affect
the common good,
that you, this is where you can
really make the most change.
And, I left office.
I was a mayor for seven years,
a governor for eight years.
I left office after 15 years
being way more impressed
with how many people
really want to get it right
and how many people truly care.
Unfortunately, there's
some really loud voices
that are interested
in being loud voices
instead of
accomplishing something.
But, my sense is,
there's a great,
I don't know if I want to
say great majority of people,
but there's a large number of
people who really truly care
and want this to be
about being better.
- Yeah, I agree, and we just
need those people to speak up.
It's almost as simple as that.
- Thanks, I really enjoyed,
I enjoyed our visit,
and I really appreciate
having the opportunity
to be on your show.
- It was my pleasure, Governor.
And the link to the book
is right down below.
Thanks a lot and
have a great day.
- You, too.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlist, all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.